c'est l'histoire d'un bateau c'est
l'histoire d'une disparition c'est
l'histoire du manureva le trimaran
d'alain trop la gdc juillet qui je pense
est venu à la barre
en 1972 le navigateur alain collard
rachète en voilier et pas n'importe
lequel
c'est un bateau conçu par un autre grand
navigateur eric tabarly
il ne s'appelle pas encore le manureva
mais le pen duick iv
il est très puissant les très homogène
et très rigide
j'ai aucun problème pour manoeuvrer tout
seul bongani il ne faut pas plus de
trois mois à lomé au bateau pour
s'apprivoiser
j'ai enfin eu des vents pour benji cat
j'ai eu des vents qui me poussait
j'avais le vent dans le vent dans le dos
et je pouvais lancé le bateau dans des
dents les cavalcades en survitesse
absolument dément à bord de pen duick iv
cette même année 72
alain colas remporte la transat anglaise
et décide de rebaptiser son voilier
désormais il s'appelle le manureva
l'oiseau du voyage en tahitien mais les
choses se gâtent en 1975 le navigateur
est blessé au port de la trinité-sur-mer
son pied est broyée par un cordage dans
le même temps j'ai commencé
trois ans plus tard le 5 novembre 1978
nouvelle aventure pour alain colas le
médecin le déclare apte à naviguer
il est sur la ligne de départ de la
toute première édition de la route du
rhum
il est parmi les premiers de la course
quand le 16 novembre
voici ce qu'ils communiquent à rmc je
suis dans l'oeil du cyclone et n'y a
plus de ciel tout et amalgames il y a
que des montagnes d'eau autour de moi
depuis aucun signe de vie d'alain colas
ni dumas n'y aurait pas maintenant vous
parler d'un homme que la presse est un
petit peu l'opinion sont doucement en
train d'oublier
alors que tout espoir n'est pas perdu
alain colas ketin vraiment arrivé au
manureva les rumeurs n'ont pas tardé à
fuser attaqué par des pirates coup de
com du navigateur certains m'ont dit
caché sur une île déserte un faux
message en bouteille a même été trouvé
pendant que mon frère est en train
d'advenir qu'il a peut-être plus d'eau
que rien à bouffer des espèces de salon
qui raconte ce genre d'histoire d'autres
ont été plus inspiré gainsbourg
en 1979 écrit la chanson manureva pour
alain chamfort jane birkin était la
marraine du bateau
quant au disque c'est un succès un
million d'exemplaires vendus
[Musique]
oh